are there Steve Kaufman today I want to
talk about getting to output now
obviously you know that I'm a believer
in import developing comprehension
developing vocabulary specifically
passive vocabulary at least initially
but eventually you want to speak well
eventually to speak well you have to
speak a lot until you understand well
it's difficult to speak a lot but there
are things you can do and of course
there are language exchange sites you
can find language partners at link we
have an exchange where you can talk to
native speakers there are many
opportunities on the internet to meet
people even if you aren't in the country
where the language is spoken but I would
just like to touch on a few tips some of
the things that I find useful to do at
link first of all when I read a text
where we have the audio and we have the
text i save words and i save phrases all
right now one thing we can do to liven
it up because we want to mine this
material for words and phrases that we
can use one thing we can do is to record
ourselves speaking pronouncing these
phrases particularly phrases if you save
some good phrases now on the link page
on the right hand side there's a list of
all the words and phrases that you have
saved but to isolate the phrases you
need to go to the vocabulary page and
then there's a little button that you
can click on which says only phrases or
something like that phrase is only now
that'll bring up all the phrases you
have ever saved but there's also a
filter there that allows you to filter
by creation date so that if you then
click on you know by creation date the
most recent phrases that you have saved
will show up there so then you can
record these i use wiretap studios but
there's lots of software out there for
recording and then you can take away and
you can listen to these phrases on your
mp3 player so you are reinforcing these
phrases in your mind you're practicing
pronouncing these phrases and then you
can
view them in flash cards and in the
flash cards they have text to speech for
each of these phrases at link in most of
our languages I find that for individual
words and phrases text speech is very
helpful and so then you might be able to
correct your pronunciation you might
even want to redo your recording of them
so that's one thing you can do another
thing while we're on the subject
sometimes you have things that you want
to express or you want to develop
vocabulary in a particular area another
thing you can do is to find same
material in your own language on the
internet put it into google translate
that'll translate it into the target
language you can then import that as a
lesson in to link now and then you can
do the same thing saving phrases now
there will be aspects of the google
translate translation that are not
accurate there will be mistakes however
I find that it's quite good enough in
order to acquire specific vocabulary
specific phrasing for a particular area
so if it's medical terms or economic
terms or or simply how to express
certain you know why therefore because
from my point of view if you put all
those in some text that you grabbed from
the internet or which even you you
create yourself in your own language
translated in the google translate bring
it in the link and then go through and
do the same thing as i suggested collect
out the phrases identify the phrases
record them listen to it then do it
again in flash cards comparing to the
text to speech so all of this is getting
you it's an ability to mine that content
for useful words and phrases that you're
over time gradually going to be able to
use in your conversation so i hope
that's useful i look forward to your
comments bye for now